[Music]
hey don't forget sunscreen
you know we play indoors right that's
what spf 15 is for
come on let's go we're late the docks
are a powerhouse organization
the record 10 state championship a
little different than the ducks of the
90s
i got to cut you i mean at this age if
you can't be great at hockey don't
bother
don't bother mom please shouldn't kids
be able to play sports for
fun stephanie you brought two private
trainers to your kids
hockey practice oh i'm a pediatric
sports psychologist
ah okay we are out of here
the ducks don't get to take hockey away
from you stories without a few let downs
are boring
i want you to think about all the other
kids who've been told that they're too
small or too slow they just want to get
out there and play freaks
is he doing a trick let's start our own
team
look at this your first teammate i would
not be an asset physically
i have more of a podcast body
in order to be a team you just have to
have home rank and a coach
what about gordon bombay gordon bombay
gordon bombay i'm guessing you didn't
see the sign
i hate hockey and i don't like kids you
run an ice rink
weird huh you are losers we're not
losers
did you not just see that do your job
arrest someone no give up enough
we both know you can make such a big
difference with these kids i've spent my
entire life
chasing hockey and i have absolutely
nothing to show for it
you have us your path is
you have taken too much crap for too
long
not where i thought i would be but i'm
trying to do something different here
this is bigger than hockey this is about
you standing up for yourself
the true measure of a person is not in
how many times they fall down but it's
how many times they pick themselves back
up you got to make this happen for
yourself
guys come on now don't get discouraged
okay that's why we watch game tapes to
get better it's like a master class
in seconds
[Music]
bye